hey today we're going to do an
introduction to 3js camera setups
how they work and how to use them along
with lighting
getting a solid understanding of cameras
is pretty essential for a good
experience in games there's a lot of
work behind getting the camera to move
fluidly throughout the scene following
the action in a way that feels
natural players may not realize that as
you transition from one state in the
game to the next
the camera may have to completely change
its logic and behavior
i've worked on projects where we had an
engineer whose full-time job was just
working on different camera logic
anyway what we'll cover today is the
different cameras that 3js
offers we'll go over them one by one and
explore how they work
and how to use them in javascript i'm
going to take a quick second here to
remind you to
subscribe if you haven't already so for
anyone interested in knowing how to
define these in code
it's pretty simple you instantiate
instances of either a perspective camera
or an orthographic camera with a few
parameters
so in this case i'll start by defining a
prospective camera
and we just need to feed in a few
parameters and we're all set
i'll also define the second camera here
an orthographic camera
again there's a bunch of parameters and
that's pretty much it
down here in your render loop you render
using the camera of choice and voila
you've instantiated a camera and used it
but there's a lot of parameters
let's go look at the docs now to take a
quick look at the different parameters
these cameras take
starting with the prospective camera
here on the 3gs site we've got the
public api for the camera constructor
and it's got these four
inputs fov or field of view aspect
near and far so just from the docs
themselves the descriptions are pretty
sparse
field of view is the vertical field of
view then you've got the frustum aspect
ratio
and the near and far plane you can
scroll down to see if there's much more
detail but there isn't
this isn't the fault of the three js
docks they're pretty complete
the problem is that by themselves these
inputs don't mean a whole lot
you need to be familiar with perspective
projections to begin with
if we look at the orthographic camera
docs it's not that different
here's the constructor for the
orthographic camera and it's got
six parameters left right top bottom
near far with the descriptions again
being incredibly sparse again this
assumes you're familiar with
orthographic projections
otherwise these values mean nothing so
let's get familiar with these
projections then
and we'll fully understand what these
cameras do both cameras have what's
called a view frustum which is a fancy
word for the shape of the viewing area
they're defined slightly differently for
each camera for reasons we'll explore in
a second
the first camera we'll look at is the
perspective camera which
more closely mimics natural cameras aka
the one in your pocket
it's also the camera that you're used to
seeing in games
let's look a bit deeper at how they work
so a normal real camera
like the one in your phone has a field
of view if we represent a camera by this
little eyeball thing here we can draw in
the field of view
and see that nearby objects appear a lot
larger or take up more space in the view
than far away objects a perspective
camera pretty much
works the same way you've got four
values that define the viewing volume
the field of view and aspect ratios work
together to form the sides of the volume
so you can see here the field of view
basically changes how narrow or wide the
lens of the camera is
the aspect ratio determines how wide it
is relative to the height
the reason this is usually canvas width
divided by height is because most
monitors are wider than they are tall
usually about 1.77 times wider than they
are tall
although i did get this as a christmas
present recently which is wide to the
point of absurd and the aspect ratio
will be a bit higher
so 5 aspect ratio roughly determine the
shape of the viewing volume
but there's two more parameters near and
far you need to provide basically a
range or min
max for the viewing area the near plane
defines the closest you can get to the
camera
anything closer than that will get
clipped and will be invisible
same with the far plane this defines the
maximum or how far you can see before
things get clipped
anything past this point will be
invisible now there's a really good
reason for the near and far plane
and that's because computers don't have
unlimited precision for representing
numbers
in fact their ability to represent
numbers with 32-bit floats is very
finite
about six to seven decimal places we
touched on this in another tutorial on
generating planets
or precision issues cropped up when
doing this at planetary scales
but it's not just at planetary scales
bad choices in near far planes can cause
some really serious problems in the
scene
so carefully choosing your near and far
planes is unfortunately
part of graphics programming if i were
to for example
choose an extremely close near plane and
a really far-out far plane
what you end up with is called zed
fighting due to precision issues
that's a prospective camera now let's
understand what an
orthographic camera is now while a
prospective camera mimics a real camera
an orthographic camera has no physical
counterpart in reality
in a prospective camera objects close to
the camera appear larger than those
further away
but that's not the case with an
orthographic camera
in fact objects near or far appear
exactly the same size
and that's by design nothing gets scaled
based on distance
everything appears the same size the
perspective
camera's view frustum is this pyramid
type volume
while the orthographics is more like a
rectangle so if you have this point here
representing an orthographic camera
there are six values that are used to
define the camera
there's the left right top bottom which
define the extents of the sides
and finally you have the same near and
far planes so what's an orthographic
camera used for if most games use
perspective cameras
well first of all most of the ui all the
2d stuff that's composited onto the
screen
that's probably done with an
orthographic projection
secondly there's still use for it in
actual games
you might also be more familiar with the
term isometric view which can be
achieved using an orthographic
projection
now that we know roughly what the
different cameras are let's go back to
the code
as you saw before instantiating a camera
isn't that difficult
pretty much this single line of code
here you can also move and redirect the
camera by setting the position
and that's as easy as using
camera.position.set
and supplying the xyz coordinates i'll
load this up and here we've got a simple
scene and the camera is looking at these
objects
now i can use the slider here to update
the y-coordinate on the camera
and as you can see the camera starts
floating up and down
there's also the rotation of the camera
and that's exposed by the camera's
rotation property
or you can use the quaternion property
directly they're just different ways to
access the same thing
using the rotation property gives you
the euler angles
so you can just set the xyz directly or
you can use the quaternion property
which is a bit more advanced
quaternions are a whole subject on their
own but for simple projects
using euler angles is going to be just
fine anyway i'll expose the rotation on
the z-axis here
so quick aside you've got three axes
x y and z and when you rotate on an axis
what you're doing is rotating around
that axis
so if i have a character that's standing
and i want them to turn naturally
you'd rotate on the y axis if i want
them to literally turn upside down
the x or z will do the trick so i've
exposed the rotation
on the z axis and back in the demo here
if i start cranking the slider for the
rotation
we start to spin lastly if you're trying
to follow
a character around setting these
rotations by hand gets complicated
quickly
since you're trying to rotate the camera
in a way that faces the character
and the math is not trivial luckily you
have this lookout function which handles
setting up the rotation for you
and all you do is supply the point you
want the camera to face and three gas
just works on math magic to set up the
rotation anyway this was just meant to
be an introduction to 3d cameras
there's a ton more to cover but ideally
after watching this you at least have a
passing
understanding of the underlying 3d
mechanics for both types of cameras
like always like and subscribe codes
available on github
see you next time cheers
you